what was that like for you that that
time in your life is probably the worst
moment that I passed through my life
since my
my father died you know when you have a
kid that you expect that everything will
be normal and you have that
problem it's it's hard you know as human
being that I am in Georgina why we had
quite difficult moments because
we don't understand why
happened to us
was difficult to be honest was was very
very difficult to to understand what's
going what's going on in that in that
period of our life
as you know the football carry on there
are so fast many competitions the
football don't stop we are many many
competitions
and pass through in that moment was
probably the most difficult moment that
I had in my life me and my my family
especially Geo that was was tough it's
such a difficult situation again where
you're mourning the terrible loss of
your little baby boy
but also celebrating the birth of your
beautiful daughter try to explain
sometimes to my family and even my close
friends they say I never felt to be
happy and sad in the same moment yes I
never felt it is hard to explain
um so difficult so difficult it's you
don't know if you cry or you don't know
if you smile yes because it's something
that
you don't know how to react you don't
know what to do to be honest